foreign
and my children have never really gotten
along we can't do holidays together or
anything else for that matter I try not
to bring up anything to do with my kids
the only arguments we ever have have to
do with my kids to be honest that's a
huge deal though it's like saying the
only thing that's hard for me is
breathing
[Music]
what up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show so glad that you are with
us we're talking about marriage and
parenting and mental health in
relationship whatever whatever you got
going on we'll sit there with you sit
here with you I guess not over there but
here
it's the best show on Earth ever that
has ever existed and here's what's so
great
um I'm traveling the country and back on
the road and just meeting you and seeing
you behind closed doors and being able
to make eye contact and listening to
your stories about how you're talking to
your kids a little different you are
meeting with your spouse a little bit
different you are dating a little bit
different you're leaving your job
because your boss is an idiot and you
deserve but like all these people are
you're making changes in your life and
I'm so grateful the show's cool but
seeing what you do with the show and
what you how you look in the mirror and
say I'm gonna make my life different
after this that is so incredible so
thank you so much for being with us
um if you want to be on this show give
me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 or go to
John deloney.com ask ask fill out the
form and it will go to Kelly and she'll
decide your fate and then send it on to
Jenna all right let's get to Christy
in Old Milwaukee
Kelly's favorite beer all right what's
up Christy
yeah hi Dr John how are you doing today
I'm so good how are you
good
what's happening oh my question for you
I'm gonna I'm gonna read it so that I'm
a little more coherent I'm a little
nervous but um don't be nervous but
coherence is so good
yes
um how can I stop lying to save my
marriage
so I've been married to my husband for
almost four years
um this is a second marriage for both of
us and we both have grown children who
live on our own uh more empty nesters
now but my husband and my children have
never really gotten along and I always
kind of feel stuck in the middle
um we can't do holidays together or
anything else for that matter I try not
to bring up anything to do with my kids
if I have a day off and I plan to spend
it with my daughters I try to avoid the
topic
um he tells me he never wants to
discourage me from spending time with
them but for some reason I always feel
guilty if I even bring up anything that
has to do with them
um why so if you ask what I'm
I feel like with my my ex-husband was
very controlling
and very emotionally abusive
and I know my husband now is not like
that at all but I still feel like
it's a I don't know if I'd say it's a
defense mechanism
but but why can't your kids and him be
in the same room I can do holidays
together
I feel like they've done things in the
past that kind of sabotage certain
things who's like your kids
my kids yes
so like for instance they showed up
really late to our wedding that was one
thing my husband will bring up
um and it was a very small wedding it
was just a handful of us and we couldn't
do anything because they hadn't shown up
um how long ago was that
that was almost four years ago
and how old are these kids
they're in their 20s they're I mean
they're all adults they all live on
their own two of them are married
but what I'm getting at is
so your 20 year old kids
they had a little Timber tantrum power
play
on your wedding that was dumb and
immature like 20 year olds are
all right your grown-up husband
I can't sit back and be like hey the
family that they thought they were gonna
have has been ex has exploded and I'm
new and I'm gonna take some getting used
to and I'm gonna have to be the mature
one here for a season he can't do that
he has to act like a child too
things that way yeah
and so I end up like trying not to bring
up anything that has to do with my kids
which really shouldn't be an issue but
it seems like we absolutely the only
argument the only arguments we ever have
have to do with my kids to be honest
that's a huge deal though it's like
saying the only thing that's hard for me
is breathing
right that's that's your life those are
your kids
I know is he is your husband
um
does he I hear this often when folks get
remarried and they marry somebody who
wants to pretend their new spouse's
previous life didn't happen didn't exist
so that they can have them all to
themselves and I hear it's often women
who have men with children
and they want to pretend that that ex
that that man was not with somebody else
and had kids with somebody else and had
intense intimate moments with somebody
else and the kids are annoying it's rare
that I see it flipped but but here we
are is it possible that your husband
just wants to pretend that your previous
world didn't exist and he's got you all
to himself
I don't feel like that's the case I feel
like more he's I I think from his
perspective I tend to baby my kids
and so he's just like let them be adults
like they're on their own now let them
fend for themselves kind of thing
whereas I always feel like
I'm still around and I'm still her mom
and so like yes I still want to be there
to support my kids what does support
mean
like that but just so he doesn't want
you talking to them
no he'll he'll say I can I mean and he
says I he doesn't want to interfere with
my relationship with them yeah I know
but he is
everybody is so you've heard me say this
on the show a million times behavior is
a language he can say whatever he wants
I don't give a crap what he says I care
what he does and almost as as important
as what he does it's how he makes you
feel whenever you're doing whatever it
is you're doing
and if you're on the phone with your
daughter or you're on the phone with
your son
who happens to be an immature 20
something year old they're gonna have to
get in a long line on that one
and do you suddenly feel like I have to
shut this thing down or I'm gonna have
hell to pay in this house and it might
not be physical hell to pay or it might
not be verbal hell to pay but it's that
disgusting look at oh my gosh I got
married an idiot I made some soft old
lady like and you have to lie and shut
it down
um behavior is a language dude
right
yeah
I feel like like I can talk with my kids
without a problem but I feel like if I I
work options and so I feel almost guilty
on my the days that he has to go to work
where I can just spend a day with the
kids or spend the day with my grandkids
and that's on you that's on you those
are your feelings
now let me push on that a bit
you feel guilty you feel all these
things and you said some of that is
lingering from your past marriage where
maybe if you did spend a day with the
kids you had hell to pay when you got
home
are you unfairly
um taking a picture of your old
ex-husband and cutting it out and
pasting it on the face of your current
husband
has he ever said when he gets home from
work like oh my gosh you're not here
you're with your stupid kids has he ever
said that
no have you ever said that has he ever
even hinted at that
no he hasn't
um why are you doing that to yourself
that's a really good question
because I do feel like I I do have a
tendency to put him in that place of
like
and he'll tell me I'm not your ex I'm
not
this person that used to belittle you
and say things
like that
um so here's the deal people people lie
for on the whole for one of three
reasons number one there's there have a
pathology right they're psychotic they
think that they're smarter than
everybody around them
the second reason people lie is to to
keep themselves safe
like I have to lie or somebody's like
are your kids in that house no they're
not there I'm gonna lie to keep myself
not harmed the third one is
um to preserve relationship it's social
status is in the nerd literature I I'm
gonna try to keep this fantasy going
that everything's okay
which one of the reasons of those three
reasons are the reasons that you don't
tell your husband the truth that you're
running around behind his back
do you feel unsafe are you trying to
pretend that everything's okay
um I feel like it's it probably is to be
safe but it's more
to avoid an argument
no but you're not telling me about any
argument you have
why would you argue
we end up arguing over
I guess every once in a while it will be
spending time with the kids or how come
you're with I I know I'm talking in
circles
um
here's what it sounds like if I'm gonna
be super honest with you
yes
it sounds like he's
um
an abusive jerk that you're trying to
protect but also quietly covertly ask
questions on how you can live in that
world
or
you have created a fantasy narrative
that he is going to be bad too and so
you curb your actions and behaviors when
it comes to the most important people in
your life which are your kids
and then you blame him
for your behavioral choices
that he has nothing to do with
and then in the blame you all get in a
fight and you end up arguing about
things it's one of those two things
which one is it
I feel like it's probably the second one
you don't go visit your kids when you
want to or they say hey mom come over
and see us and you're like well I gotta
be home because husband gets home soon
and then he gets home 20 minutes late
and you are enraged
not because he's 20 minutes late or not
because he came home not because you're
not happy to see him but because he kept
you from seeing your kids and really he
didn't and then you act short or you act
a little bit mean and then he responds
to that and now we're in a fight and
you're saying the fight's about the kids
and it's really not is that fair
it can be yeah yeah I would say that's
fair
I am concerned that he isn't sitting
down saying hey we have to heal this
we all have to be able to be in a room
together
or is it you keeping everybody from
being in the same room together
no I
know I brought that up I'm like I think
this is getting ridiculous yes correct
um but at the same time he's like
they're not going to want to hear what I
have to say and it's just gonna blow up
and that's how he feels what is he what
is he gonna try to parent them
no no I think he would just tell them to
basically just grow up and stop acting
like children ironically because that's
kind of how he's acting
it's a hundred percent he's like I'm
taking my ball and going home what an
immature guy like
what are they what are they doing that's
I'm fascinated by this what are they
doing that is so immature
they got jobs they're financially on
their own and they call their mom once a
week or twice a week to check in like
what is so immature about what they how
they live
well I'd say
I'd say they pretty much every day for
something or other they'll ask me for
advice for a different thing
especially my girls were real close so
we do talk quite often so one thing
that's super common
about
um if you lived under the rule of of an
abusive spouse
for a period of time
and the result is a divorce but that
abuse and that hunkering down happens
years before the papers are finalized
mm-hmm
kids in a protective spouse will circle
the wagons and have a very deep
connected sometimes a mesh sometimes un
um healthy but often very tight knit
relationship because they had to to
survive
and I think that was us
we had a very very close relationship
and so you have to be careful as their
adults to not use them now to prop you
up
and
you have to teach them how to fly
and say things like here's a good
example I called
um this is several years ago now I had a
student who had passed away and I had to
make an announcement to a bunch of his
friends
and I called my mentor the guy that
first taught me how to make these kind
of phone calls and I said hey here's
what I'm about to do and he and he said
John listen
what you just said is right and you
don't need to call me anymore you you
know what you're doing and I trust you
they trust you and they're lucky to have
you
and so you see what I'm saying like he
heard me he affirmed what I was doing
and then he also ended with and you
don't need to call me every time
and so it feels good when your kids call
you every day and ask you for questions
and ask you for I should do this should
do this I feel so good and so empowering
and at some point you're using them to
make you feel important
that's that's a heavy burden for your
kids to carry
so if they call you to ask you about car
insurance you can say yeah I would use
this the insurance we use and I like it
and by the way you don't need to call me
every time for car insurance I trust you
you're a good kid
see what I'm saying there's just little
nuggets to say there you go
to more Empower them and not exactly
have them depend on me fair but all of
that is gonna take some healing time
and it sounds like honestly everybody
needs to grow up
you him kids everybody needs to grow up
and he doesn't have any position right
now to be lecturing your chill your
grown children
what he does have is hey uh I'm watching
my wife wither and die here
because I'm forcing her to not be whole
or you Christy are choosing to not be
whole
because you're not going all in on this
marriage right
I feel like I have to live in two
different lives like I my lives don't
mesh
I don't know if that makes sense it does
but I want you when you hear this call
come out I want you to hear how many
times you said the words I feel I feel I
feel
and I want you to write down what you
and then I want you to demand evidence
from those feelings because I have a
sense that those feelings are very very
real but they are not telling you the
truth
that could be
and maybe you take husband out
um for a lunch on a Saturday or for
breakfast on a Saturday and you have
spent two weeks writing down your
quote-unquote feelings
and you can ask him hey I'm going to run
these feelings by you these are mine
these are all mine
these are stories I'm telling myself as
brene Brown says and that's how me and
my wife do it the stories I'm telling
myself are
I have to live two lives because you
can't be around my kids and if you are
around my kids you feel like you gotta
lecture them the story I'm telling
myself is our marriage isn't going to
ultimately work out because I'm not
going to choose my kids um you over my
kids the story I'm telling myself is I'm
a terrible mom because you say I talk to
my children too much and they're adults
and I want you to go down all those
stories and let him respond to those
things
and at some point you're gonna have to
decide
I'm going to let my needs be heard and
my needs are I need everybody that I
love and care about in the same room my
grown kids and my husband
and I gotta quit living two lives and
your grown kids can opt out they can say
we don't like this too we want to be
gone and they can they get to do that
[Music]
they get to do that and I guess at the
end of the day your husband gets to
choose that too he's a grown-up and you
get to decide whether you want to be
married to a man who won't be in the
same room with your kids that's on you
but at the end of the day you all have
to make some hard choices but those hard
choices start with you being honest
about
feelings and reality you got to choose
reality and
you got to be willing to have your needs
be met just say them out loud and say
here's what I I need everybody under the
same roof I need everybody acting like
adults and I'm willing to go first
I think this is a solvable problem
Christy I really do
I think you might be getting in your own
way
maybe for the first time in your life
you can allow yourself to finally be
loved when you're just gonna have to
practice what that feels like it's going
to take a season
we'll be right back
I've got a word from our sponsor
betterhelp listen I've been on both ends
of therapy in my life I've gotten it
myself and I've walked people through it
and I've seen the benefits from both
sides when someone owns their past and
the cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right we are back and it's time for
everybody's favorite facts are your
friends let's do it
foreign
managers impact employee mental health
more than therapists or their spouse
that's the title of this new article
here
whoa that's all I'm saying whoa
if this is true this is this is
shapeshifter for most of us because the
the all of the data suggests that the
most important decision a person makes
is who they marry
um a great partnership with your spouse
ends up in a much larger net worth it
ends up in longer life it ends up in
Better Health better happiness all these
metrics go this way and a bad spouse
somebody who um you're always at war
with
um leads to negative metrics and so I've
always told young people always the most
important decision is not where you go
to college not what you major in it's
who you decide to spend the rest of your
life with
and so when an article comes out it says
managers impact employees mental health
more than their spouse or partner or
more than their therapist
we gotta stop that bus and back that
thing up all right so here's what it
says the workforce Institute at ukg
surveyed 35 the 3 400 people across 10
countries to find out the role managers
play in influencing their staffer State
of Mind
in fact
managers impact workers mental health
more than both doctors and therapists
according to the study now really quick
I'm going to give you a 0.02 second
lesson on reading articles
this in big bold letters here's what the
title of this article is managers impact
employees mental health more than
therapists and as much as a spouse or
partner
if you read it really quick it jumbles
it all together so it says it's about as
much as a spouse or partner okay now go
so make sure that the the title matches
what you're actually reading down here
those are often disconnected because
they want you to click on the title and
then you read it and it's like ah well
maybe not but that's not here
it's not surprising that 60 of those
surveys said that their job is the
biggest Factor influencing their mental
health now I want to push back on that
for a second
here's in in real quick we've created a
planet a universe a state of being
where all of us owe people money
we're all in debt
whether it's student loans whether it's
car loans whether it's housing whether
it's a rent whatever we all owe people
money and we're the loneliest generation
in human history we have nobody we got
nobody we have old high school friends
and we have long text threads full of
memes with that's it we have a couple of
college buddies who are in your sorority
or fraternity or whatever group you paid
to be friends with or on Old sports
teams or whatever
maybe you got a couple people from your
high school youth group I I we're lonely
and we've pulled the string we've pulled
the tether on
um stories that unite cultures otherwise
known as religions
we're all like eh we're too smart for
that stuff now that's not real
and what we have are exhausted lonely
untethered people who have one common
place left
the workplace
and so now the workplace is having to
teach us about issues of diversity about
sex ed because we didn't get that at
home we didn't get that at school
they're having to teach us uh they have
to provide us Health Care
they have to provide us a purpose they
have to provide us paycheck you see how
the workplace now is the Baseline for
all human Humanity it's the last great
line of defense
and so when people say my job is the
source of my mental health issue I don't
think so I think it's we've created a
world where the only connecting feature
left is work it's the only thing we got
left that defines us as a as a community
as a group of people it's the only place
I see humans anymore
and if you work remotely can I help you
man
all you see is Toddlers and your spouse
and jeez
so
I'll just move on
a whopping 64 percent of respondents
said that work negatively impacts their
well-being
it's wild
work should be the thing that gives you
purpose and meaning and feels so right
and then you go home
and then you go connect with your
friends and then you go connect with
your faith community or you go do your
acts of service Etc
coincidentally um there's a direct
correlation between feeling unable to
balance work and home priorities with
poor mental health so now you see what
what's happening here we've created
unstable wildly out of balance lives and
we blame work for it
over 80 percent of employees worldwide
and seventy percent of workers in the US
would take a pay cut for a job that so
better supports their mental Wellness
what I want people to do is to actually
sit down and write down on a piece of
paper what is mental Wellness for me
what would that actually mean
time with friends fun
if it's video game time and doing
nothing time and laying around time I'm
going to tell you that's not mental
health that's numbing Behavior that's
opposite of mental health if it's time
to go on adventures and time to go
hiking and time to go hunting and time
to do painting or whatever play music
that now we're getting into building a
life worth living
the overwhelming majority of HR is a
continuing article and c-suite leaders
think their employ their workplace has a
positive impact on work or mental health
but half of the employees agree and I'll
tell you this I've seen this almost
every single place I've ever worked ever
ever consulted
and we've seen this in the data over the
last 25 to 50 years the disconnect
between
mid managers and lower entry-level
workers up through middle management and
that could be a six-figure job as a
middle manager and the execs
those that can afford all of the yoga
classes and the special stuff and the
and the massages and they're not they're
not worried about I can't afford eggs
right there's a gap between here's the
world we're creating I once was at a
place where the boss was like we don't
have politics here where we we're at
this at this workplace and I laughed and
said oh yeah you do yeah you do and
they're like no we don't we don't do
politics here it's like oh for sure you
do for sure we don't have a dress code
here you for sure have a dress code here
right so there's a disconnect between
the world that senior execs think
they've created and the world being
experienced by others and the easy thing
exacts I'm talking to you is to say
um I don't care they got to get in line
cool
and what they're telling you is they're
falling apart
they're falling apart
so I'm talking to both the employees and
the leaders here the article goes on to
say how managers can influence their
workers mental health for the better and
I actually agree with all of the points
here I think they're great
first one is leaders need to avoid
burying their heads in the sand and
instead make mental health a global
topic of discussion within their teams
yes start having conversations
let people know that if they're not okay
or not well here's where resources are
here's what my expectations are for how
you need to take care of yourself here's
where you can go
and leaders make no mistake having a
somebody who's struggling with
depression struggling with anxiety show
up every day is going to decrease
performance individually and with your
whole team
you're much better off taking care of
people now they also have to get their
work done that's real you may have to
split people's jobs up to why people are
getting healthier getting whole all that
stuff's true but you got to stop bearing
your heads about you start talking about
it
um this can be uh let's see here it
could be um
increase awareness or access to
available resources there can be uh
surveys that are Anonymous just to get a
pulse on what's going on in the in the
company I think those are super helpful
sometimes people use those to lob
grenades they do they do but if you get
enough grenades at some point you
realize you're under attack and you
didn't know it
um also suggest that managers should be
open about their own personal struggles
with mental health and relationships to
destigmatize the topic
when any leader across the country asks
me how can I best support my staff
my team because they're struggling with
anxiety they're struggling with
depression they're struggling with all
these things the first thing I always
tell the leaders is you call a meeting
and let them know that you're going to a
counselor
that you are taking a little bit of time
to go get well that you and your spouse
are going to see a marriage counselor go
do that lead by example you go first
and the whole organization will
collectively
exhale and yes your shareholders can use
that against you they can they can
weaponize it your bosses your the board
members of whatever organization can be
like oh so-and-so's struggling but yes
they can do that
and now you know how your employees feel
now you know
um one last thing here
um
managers should be encouraging workers
to take more time off work
use your vacation
this happens in two ways managers turn
your phones off one of the things I love
about working at Ramsey Solutions is you
know Dave Ramsey will just pile send
emails off but they don't come until 6
a.m they've all the execs here have
fixed their email accounts so when they
send emails after a certain time it
doesn't end up in our email boxes until
the morning
because they found out they were sending
an email just off the top of their head
like hey I want to see some numbers on
this thing at 10 o'clock and then
suddenly an employee was reading it at
10 and they were up till 4am trying to
find these numbers and unable to sleep
and stressing and that was not intention
of the email at all not even close
and so there's little things like that
and then there's bigger things like an
incentive if you use all your vacation
I'll give you two more days because the
data says people who use their vacation
make your company more money
they make your company more money and I
used to be really guilty leaders when I
had a whole bunch of direct reports I
would tell them you need to take some
time off can you take some time off
but they had these big projects and so I
was actually stressing them out more
because now he's giving him time off was
that was becoming a job requirement a
responsibility
so I might have to find people to help
with those projects and say hey you got
to get out of here you got to delegate
this project to two other people I know
they can get it done or we have to
create a world where we can delegate
each other's projects because you got to
get it you gotta take a break
all this to say
when it comes to work in mental health
we've created worlds
very unhealthy worlds that our bodies
can exist in and we're blaming work for
that and I think that's ridiculous and
leaders we have to understand that we've
there's such a gap between us and
entry-level employees we have to
remember what that was like and we think
we remember but we're wrong
we have to get in the busy messy lives
of the people who are taking these
entry-level jobs these mid-management
jobs that are working their butts off
that have dreams and oh six figures in
student loan debt and they're trying to
make it all work and we have to remember
what that was like and we all think I
remember what those like we don't the
pressures are different now they're just
different
they're not better or worse they're just
different and we gotta listen we gotta
listen
and leaders we got to go first
that's why I'm always on this show
telling people I see a counselor I see a
marriage counselor I got a coach
I'm not perfect either and I do this for
a living
managers leaders we gotta go first
mental health at work by the way if your
job is causing your mental health to
collapse
you are worth something better than that
create a life worth living and find
other work I can't find the job there is
no better time in human history than to
find a new job than right now
go do it we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show what
you'd like to see more of what you like
to hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we're back let's go to Dave
right down the street here in Nashville
what's up Dave
hi uh thank you for this I just I really
appreciate the opportunity to talk to
you about this you got it man thank you
for for giving me a buzz man what's up
so I have a 17 year old son who's been
making some bad decisions lately
um my question is how to best help him
in general
and and specifically I'm wrestling with
whether or not to support him going away
to college this fall with everything
that's been going on in a I don't mean
that as a punishment I mean as just
trying to do what's best for him and try
to help
okay tell me some tell me more
okay so he has um a strong close family
history of addiction
he's very well aware of this
um about five months ago or so he got
caught using pot and um
he was caught again just a few weeks ago
and this time we see that he has some
really really bad grades as well
um
he has a good scholarship to a good
small private school and has a spot on
one of the sports teams there it seems
like a really good situation
for most 17 year olds going out to the
world
um
and I've asked him
what he wants to do from here like where
he wants to go and uh with where he's
found himself
um he says if there's anything he could
if there's no restrictions if you do
anything that he wanted to do he wants
to go to this school and go play on the
sports team
and we've had a lot of discussions about
how like these things that he's been
doing these decisions he's made are not
in line with that you know like kids
don't go on to college if they're
failing high school you know their
classes in high school
so
you know I'm scared
to send him I'm scared of sitting in a
month for failure
but I'm also scared to not send them and
and scared what would fill that void
um what he would do if he wasn't going
um
[Music]
I've had this conversation probably 5
000 times my career and I I would hug
you if you were sitting with me right
now okay yeah I know that the weight of
this it feels so heavy and it feels like
some of these moments are either or we
get this one right or there's a whole
catastrophic ending to the left and we
get this wrong and right so it feels
like there's heaviness here so let's
pull back a little bit
um you said he's got a long history of
uh family addiction
um have you struggled with addiction
no no it's um it's nobody in his
immediate family
um his uncle grandfather grandfather's
brothers and it's it's
pretty profound stuff okay
um
Brothers uncles grandparents on your
side or on wife's side
on Mom's side okay what are y'all what
do you and Mom do for a living
uh we're both in healthcare okay most um
uh like Masters level uh Healthcare
Providers okay
um
great income good at what you do
uh yes yes very solid and and yeah yeah
both pretty good at what we do I'd say
Okay
um so the next couple things I'm gonna
say
I'm I'm fishing a little bit just
admittedly okay
and normally if you were and I were
sitting down for like a coaching session
we would talk for a couple hours but I'm
gonna get cut right to the Chase and I
need you to promise me you're not going
to take some of the things I say as
indictments of ways you have failed is
that cool right yeah totally
um when somebody tells me they have a
long generational history of addiction
the first thing that comes into my mind
is a long history of performance-based
disconnection
a long history of Performance Based
the suckiest part about being a parent
of a 17 year old who smokes weed is that
weed works really well
especially on a young mind
it takes away that gnawing anxiety
you and I both know also that it kills
drive it kills sexual dysfunction it's
it's terrible for a developing brain all
those things we know that
but for a 17 year old it works
and so my question is always with a 17
year old not while you why are your
grades suddenly falling off why are you
suddenly smoking weed you got in trouble
and then also you're doing it again and
you've been doing it again
that's never my question my question is
always why are you hurting what about
your world
how are you in so much pain that this is
the only way
you can sue that pain
see how there's a difference there
yeah I I do
um let me say this and so I work with
really high performing families all over
the country have for years
and it was a revelation to me when I
found out that addiction can be really
hard drugs it can be heroin it can be
cocaine it could be all kind of things
then I learned it could be pornography
and sex
then I learned it could be 90 hour work
weeks
and it could be
we have to make this much money we have
to have this grades we have to have
clothes that look like this you got to
have cars that are clean like this and
the addiction becomes the
outer shell to Performance and these
things get carried on generationally not
always through if there's always cocaine
and heroin at some point that generation
ends but somebody picks up that baton
and says oh I'll fix this
and their life becomes one of perfection
and performance and the addiction is the
same it's just that our culture gives
you a hundred fifty thousand dollars a
year for it
I I don't think I don't believe it
that's it and what you're saying is like
we're putting pressure on him to perform
I definitely don't think that's in line
with what we've done I'd say it's
probably more the opposite is that we
have really let the kids do whatever
they want to do you want to play this
sport they play the sport you don't want
to that's okay you want to work here
fine we're not helicopter parents we're
honestly
the only reason we looked at his grades
is because we found him smoking weed
again
um
the the one I'd say the only the amount
of pressure that we give to the kids is
that with this one specifically
he does no homework at home he's
he's an awesome kid and uh but he does
he's not super studious and so the one
thing we said is like hey if you're not
going to be doing homework at home it
means your grades are good enough for
that so like 85 is minimum if you're if
you're over 85 great just you do you uh
if you're under 85 you're grounded
Monday through Friday because you should
be doing more homework and um so like
that's that that's the extent of our
together
pressure as far as to perform everything
else is just just him I mean he's he's
going to he wasn't going to play any
sports in school and he decided he
wanted to go to this one specific school
and do this one specific sport so
we're happy to support him in that
um but of course
he knows that part of that for us is
like really just two three things we've
asked for is to be you know respectful
and pleasant to be around in the house
uh your grades need to be good enough
and to not do drugs you know that's
that's really it and um
is it violated at least two out of the
three things probably more toward three
out of the three things
um just here lately
this has been a couple of weeks now
since since we caught him the second
time and he is trying I mean he is
he's doing a bunch of catch-up work
trying to get his grades better they are
starting to turn in the right direction
he was
so like disappointed in himself but also
just mad at us because he didn't agree
with kind of the things we were doing
you know we were limiting his phone use
and that didn't make sense because he
didn't do anything wrong with his phone
he just was angry so angry I was trying
so hard to
that connects more with him because you
know he's 17 he's got the keys he's just
gone all the time
um and now he's home and grounded for
the most part
um
you found yourself on a track okay sorry
no no you're good you're good man you're
a dad that loves the Sun you found
yourself on what I call a 21st century
parenting trap it's a loop
and I fall into it man so same team here
okay I got two young kids too they're
not 17 yet but they're on their way
we want to be supportive so earlier I
said I was fishing I'm happy to hear
that man that makes my heart feel good
and here's what sucks about being a
parent
we can go too far the other way to where
we create a world that feels like
there's no boundaries until Wham there
are
and so you've got a kid like my first
question to you after that is how in the
world do you have a 17 year old and you
don't know what their grades are
and so I can absolutely see you and your
wife sitting down and saying hey we are
not going to be those parents that are
lunatics that are overbearing or
whatever
and then your 17 year old who's clearly
got smart parents probably has smart
brothers and sisters and I'm just
talking about me personally who I had an
older sister who was on the Academic
Decathlon team and my younger brother
missed like two questions on the ACT and
then there was the dumb jock in the
middle of me
I had great expectations but I didn't
know how to do that
I didn't know how to study I just was
told hey if you're not doing your work
you get your crap you better be better
be here I didn't know how to bridge that
Gap and then what you've done is you've
taken away the one thing that keeps a 17
year old brain stable which is
relationships
and so you see this toggle between a
lonely brain screaming for a
reconnection and the three things that
work for a young brain to to to
um uh duct tape over disconnection
alcohol marijuana sex
and look around at all of our kids
especially when they go to college
because we unplugged them from their
world and we dropped them in a box and
we say make great choices together
and these are little brains saying I
just needed my I need my tribe I need my
gang and not getting these grades
is it you see what I'm saying so it
becomes this Loop and then he's going to
work really hard and he's really smart
he's going to get his grades up you know
that I know that he's gonna get him up
and he's gonna White Knuckle his way to
not smoking weed
so that he can finally get some Freedom
back and then his poor brain is going to
be screaming at that little 17 year old
boy with all it's got saying you got to
reconnect you gotta reconnect you gotta
reconnect and we're just gonna get on a
loop here
my recommendation the way to break the
loop is a couple fold the first one is
is less conversations you all start
doing stuff on the regular together just
you and him
and you can say like I already do that
like this is above and beyond this is
like I'm I'm you have to go to breakfast
with me once a week or twice a week and
you gotta go on walks with me in the
evening you just have to and that anger
is real and the anger is Justified I get
the anger and also it will dissipate
because it's a body saying this isn't
how it's supposed to be we're supposed
to be in relationship and it's right now
it's me versus my parents and you need
to show take that step because you're
the adult
nah man I'm with you I'm with you I'm
with you I'm with you
that's the set first one the second one
is
if there's a way to get teach him some
study skills or as a household from the
hours of this to this
the music's off and we all study that's
just the way this works my wife and I
set that up at our house like we're
we're a family full of nerds right
um so this isn't for everybody but we
just have reading time after after
school like people just plop down and
read and so it's it's kind of awkward to
not do that
um or my son will heads off into the
woods and runs around for himself
outside just to get get his wiggles out
we call him and then he comes back in
and we all just do homework for a season
and when I'm home I join in I do the
same thing but it's just a rhythm and a
routine it's not hey you got to figure
this stuff out because some 17 year olds
haven't figured that out and I'm one of
those kids and I guess I want you to see
down the road I didn't have I didn't
smoke weed in high school okay but I've
made stupid choices a lot of them
me too there's a lot of
okay so you're a perfect example like
I I
guess I wouldn't give up on this kid and
I know you're not but I I I will
you know him better than me
I'm always looking at trend lines is the
trend line heading down are we in
heading to some to some scary territory
or do we have a 17 year old who is
struggling who needed some boundaries
maybe different boundaries than his
brothers and sisters and we have to
shake the shake the snow globe a little
bit his grades are going to be fine and
maybe we're gonna have a conversation
with Coach maybe we're gonna have a
conversation with the school Counseling
Center and say hey we've struggled had
some struggles in the past we want him
to see you guys once a week hey coach I
want you to keep an eye on him and um
we're gonna watch really closely with
his grades I I don't necessarily think
that's an either ordeal I I personally
have seen kids get out of some of those
situations and really Blossom and I've
seen some extraordinary kids get their
butts kicked out of college right so
it's it's kind of bad I definitely feel
like no matter what I decide with what
to do with him
in the end it can go either way just
like you're saying and that's the that's
the suckiest part of being a parent
that's all of us right
yeah
yeah I'm scared that like because I I
can identify with him so well I made
lots of bad decisions and turned out
okay I really I feel like I turned out
okay yeah
um
but you know with I didn't have the
addiction family history stuff and I'm
I'm yeah but Hey listen Dave don't put
that up don't put that on him don't put
that on him because it's going to become
a self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah okay it's something to be aware of
but it's not prophetic it's not it's not
guaranteed it's not predetermined for
him
try like I do feel like he thinks
that we don't like him yeah we've been
trying to say like hey that's not true
we can't say all these things you can't
say like family dinners it's like it's
those were for you you're the only one
that wasn't here when we said we have to
be here for family dinners it was so we
could see you yeah so I guess my
question is that is it okay to force yes
the connection time for a while because
in general he wants to be out and doing
things with his friends he wants to be
going to play this sport he wants to go
to work so he's never around yes
okay he's finding it somewhere else
right right he's finding it somewhere
else what you just touched on I think is
um probably one of the most under
understood issues with our kids
he doesn't feel like anybody likes him
but there's a group of people at school
that does
and weed makes that feeling of my family
doesn't like me I don't like them it
takes the edge off of that burn
just does just us
and so yes there is something to be said
for I'm your dad you're 17 you live in
my house you have to have breakfast
breakfast with me once a week
we're going to see this concert together
and I want you to come with me and just
dude I sat through a Garth Brooks show
it ended up being a good time that was
not for me it was for my son that was
for my son
the Turn Style show coming up this
Summer that one's for me but not the
Garth show but find some concerts in
town you're in Nashville for God's sake
dude there's one every weekend
but you're gonna spend some old man time
and here's the deal at one of those
breakfast
you can reach across the table and say
something like this I'm gonna make this
really weird for us for a second okay
hold my hand son
and have him look at you and say I love
you and I like you you're a great kid I
would prefer to spend time with you than
some of my knuckleheaded friends
and I haven't been doing a good job of
that
and so from this day forward it's going
to be weird because I'm going to show
you that I like you and that I love you
and this house doesn't work without you
and that's a totally different
proposition you see what I'm saying
I do I get choked up just thinking about
having that conversation I it yeah and
then you can tell them everything you
want you can tell them you can tell them
you can tell them none of that matters
you gotta show it
you gotta show him and if you tell him
on your way to work and you tell them on
the way to a surgery you got to be a
part of and if you tell them on the way
to a dinner that he's not invited to
he's getting the message loud and clear
that he's kind of just in the way and he
just needs to get these grades and not
do this thing and everything's fine and
that's Performance Based connection
seeing that he's a priority on your
calendar seeing he's a priority in your
checkbook
and you are taking the step towards him
not just sitting there waiting for him
to come to you
now he's seeing Oh my dad likes me he
wants to spend time with me he laughs at
my jokes
[Music]
I can't tell you how grateful I am to
have dads like you in my neighborhood
who love their sons like you do
and I need you to hear me say this is a
trap all of us fall into which is just
this Loop we gotta get paid we gotta we
have our lives we want to do our lives
and kids I just want you to make the
grades and don't go to jail and don't do
drugs why is it so hard
some of our kids fall right in line and
others say I need a little bit more I
experience the world different you just
show me that you like me
that's hard
and that changes everything
thanks for the call my brother Dave call
anytime man come by and see me we can
hang out and have coffee here in the
lobby appreciate you man we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
Today's Show everybody's favorite Johnny
Paycheck lyrics shout out to my friend
Ken Coleman songs called Take This Job
and Shove It originally by David Allen
Coe The Great DAC
take this job and shove it I ain't
working here no more my woman done left
and took all the reasons I was working
for you better not try to stand in my
way as I'm walking out the door take
this job and shove it I ain't working
here no more
it's fantastic
I've been working in this Factory for
Nigh I'm 15 years all this time I was
watched my woman drowning in a pool of
tears and I've seen a lot of good folk
die who had a lot of bills to pay I'd
give the shirt right off my back if I
had the guts to say take this job and
shove it some of y'all need to have that
conversation today I'm looking at you
Kelly hey love you guys stay in school
bye foreign foreign